let's talk about the modern warfare
player versus the cold war player and
the true enemy which is the yearly cycle
now i'm joined here by richie bracamonte
and we spent a lot of time reading your
comments and what we were trying to
understand is
what makes players love modern warfare
and what makes players
love cold war we're not so worried about
which game is better so much as who each
game is for
now your answers made us really think
about the way we see these two games
and there's a couple questions that
we're going to answer in this episode
those are
is model warfare a true call of duty
game what do classic call of duty fans
know that modern warfare players
don't and what are the different
audiences looking for
[Music]
okay richie so let's start with why
we're talking about this which is that
the modern warfare audience and the cold
war audience
seem like they're kind of blaming each
other for what's going on right now with
the cold war takeover of modern warfare
so i want to start with you know a basic
rundown of what's going on
this year modern warfare players are a
little more upset
because of the lack of support and
things like the missing season seven
that was never given to us
uh people feel like they were robbed of
this season seven because
they moved their support to cold war
this also goes hand in hand with the
season pass and how it turned from a
modern warfare thing
into a cold war thing overnight and
while they still have the season pass
in modern warfare it's more relegated to
cold war things
warzone is the middle ground but you
know not everyone plays warzone
and there are long time fans like you
and i aaron who
are unfortunately welcoming people into
this sort of cycle that happens every
year
people who do play modern warfare and
haven't played a call of duty in a long
time or maybe
never played a call of duty are getting
the brunt of this
for the first time you know we're kind
of used to this drop in support every
year so while older fans of call of duty
know exactly what's going on not
everyone does
and we see this directly here in our
comments we've got one from
rymon over on youtube that says the cod
community is requesting support for more
time
goes recon players first time
one of the most telling things about
reading through the comments was how
classic call of duty fans were kind of
confused as to why
modern warfare players were confused
about why season 7 you know got canned
for another call of duty game because
they know
that the yearly cycle happens every year
and so the cold war players are kind of
like hey it's our turn right now but
also knowing that they're gonna get
screwed in a year this was really well
summed up by unbeaten mars who said
you can tell all the people begging for
modern warfare to keep getting content
are new to call of duty it's never
happened for any game before and never
will
black ops 2 had like three times the
players ghost had in 2014 and it still
didn't get any more dlc this is actually
really good for our next point which is
who is the modern warfare audience
so call of duty modern warfare 2019
undoubtedly attracted
probably two main types of players one
of those were people who were sick of
the call of duty formula
and wanted something new and the other
were probably lapsed milsim players
particularly you know we see a lot of
comments from battlefield players that
they were attracted to this game and it
filled a niche that battlefield
wasn't anymore it's really important to
point out that the reason that people
liked modern warfare or hated modern
warfare
were the exact same reason right so what
does that even mean what is it about
modern warfare that new players were
attracted to
well there's a couple things that we can
break it down to map design
sandbox and type of play so let's talk
about map design first
modern warfare has sort of large porous
maps it really went away from the
three-lane design they're also because
they're larger they're a little bit
slower paced which means that there's
more of a setup to gun fights there's
longer run time between gunfights
and there's probably a lot more thinking
about where you're gonna go
on a map next so that's that's a bit of
a of a slower pace
that ties into the sandbox of the game
so the sandbox comes from
a lot of things but the main one that
people love is playing with loadouts so
a comment that we've had in in previous
episodes was
one thing that modern warfare did really
well that cold war lacks his caliber
conversion kits for some guns
the gunsmith in modern warfare allows
you to characterize and personalize your
weapons to yourself and each gun feels
different and unique
modern warfare gave you enough rope to
hang yourself with you could build a bad
gun in modern warfare that's how good of
a sandbox it was right it lets you make
mistakes it lets
you play with weapons and it let you
turn weapons into other weapons
and um learn how that how they work and
then configure them differently and play
with them in a different way so that
sandbox aspect of it is it's way less
controlled and it can lead to
you know bad things happening if that's
not what you're interested in and then
that that brings us to the last point
which is something i'm gonna get in
trouble for here but
camping camping is a big point of
contention between modern warfare
players
and cold war players so the open porous
maps of modern warfare allowed for a lot
of
camping or you know people who hung back
and and did sniping
and i'm not going to judge someone
whether they like that or not
as a player it's a personal preference
something that i've
mentioned this in the past is that i
don't mind camping to me
it's actually a skill set that somebody
has and a good camper is somebody who
can out think you
right so like they get you and then they
get you from a different position and
then they move again
or they move back to the first position
it's kind of a thinking man's game
and a lot of people who hate campers i'm
gonna say this it's because they out
thunk you
you know like they've they've they've
been able to predict where you're gonna
go next and they've shifted position and
got you again and that is really
frustrating
hey johnny boy
hey man you gotta stop camping dude
oh really okay so that is the audience
that modern warfare appeals to now let's
talk about cold war
james b said even though cold war is an
unfinished mess i enjoy it way more than
modern warfare modern warfare has
god-awful map design
it's designed for camping safe spaces
and dumb mechanics like mounting and
leaning that make no sense in a call of
duty game cold war has that fast paced
arcade feel that i look for in a call of
duty game
richie who does cold war appeal to and
what does that fan love in their games
for the cold war crowd it's it's more of
a classic arcade
fan base uh it's it's it's faster pace
the maps are classically three lanes
they've got they're good for all sorts
of game modes
the guns there's no like there's no
extensive gunsmithing like there was in
modern warfare like your attachment has
one job the gameplay is faster there's a
lot less camping
and there are things like ninja and
other ways to sneak around the map
so that you can play more aggressive
unlike modern warfare with its big maps
that sort of discourages that sort of
aggressive play style for better or
worse so in general
cold war is for more the arcadey classic
style
uh call of duty player especially black
ops it's a very refined version of that
it feels like a lot of these players
also consider something like black ops 2
to be the
the pinnacle of call of duty game design
black ops 2 was important in a lot of
very big ways
it was the perfect storm of a lot of
things really like youtube was on the
rise
so people were using like theater mode
to make all these sick edits
clans were coming up and league play was
introduced so
you know we got to hear more and more
about the faze clan or optic clan
and things like that they were getting
popularity black ops 2's maps were also
just
so memorable so much so that they're
converting them over to
cold war like you know raid that's a
great map for
all sorts of game modes a lot of them
had that classic three-lane design we
talked about but like perfected some of
those maps are just
unforgettable and they're built in such
a way so where you can't really
hang out and snipe for too long there
are some you know secret spots and jumps
and stuff like that but
you know for every spot that you can
camp out in there's another one with
like a barrel like right in the way or
something to block you
and prevent you from camping out too
long black ops 2 also had like some of
the greatest zombies maps the most
memorable maps there
um and they started to build the story
off the zombies map so it just wasn't
like a survival
survival based game mode anymore it was
uh it was more of a story
including like the transit map like
that's one of that's a fan favorite or
mob of the dead you know they did they
were hitting
zombies really hard really well in that
in black ops 2
and it was just a special time where
like a lot of things were
hitting their stride it was a pinnacle
for a lot of people
myself included it was it was up there
as one of my favorite it's probably my
favorite
black ops games but for a lot of other
people
it's like the best it's like it it's the
pinnacle
and it's hard to disagree with that boys
let's get to work
okay so this comes down to i think one
of the most important comments that i
read that really
got me thinking about the difference
between modern warfare and cold war and
this came from
steven 34 i love cold war it plays a lot
like black ops 1.
modern warfare was not a true call of
duty it felt more like a rainbow or a
battlefield
if i want those experiences i'll play
those franchises instead
call of duty is supposed to be an arcade
shooter for fun now richie
i think you and i both agree that the
game that appeals to us between these
two
is the model warfare 2019 but this posed
a really legitimate question
is modern warfare 2019 a real
call of duty game and i think honestly
when i did some
soul searching on this one yeah no it's
not like the reason that people love
modern warfare 2019
is because it's not a classic call of
duty game that's why they were attracted
to it that's why they're upset that it's
not
being supported continuously like you
know battlefield games were with many
dlcs that sometimes lasted beyond a year
it's not what they're used to and that's
why people who love cold war
are so confused because they are classic
call of duty players they know how the
yearly cycle works and
cold war is that classic arcade game
this explained a lot to me as to as to
why these two fan bases were in conflict
and again i think the big problem here
is not that people like different things
it's that they were kind of
shoved together recently not just
sharing war zone but as we mentioned at
the top of the show
cold war completely took over the modern
warfare store like you fire at modern
warfare and you see
cold war and you're getting unlocked for
cold war and i think that also leads to
the question
you know can activision break away from
the yearly cycle do they know what they
have here
and are they willing to not just do a
yearly call of duty game because if they
do a yearly call of duty game
the cold war fans know they're gonna get
screwed in a year
you know like their game's not gonna be
supported in a year either yeah
it's it's it's messy it's it's
polarizing it's all over the place
because people
who come in from other games that
enjoyed modern warfare
because of the different experience you
know they got a they got their full year
of support
it made activision billions of dollars
people
loved it you know less people hated it
but they were still haters of course
a lot of people loved it brought in tons
of people and tons of money and then the
next game
was a total 180 back to the classic call
of duty style so
those people who were hoping for support
were hanging on for season seven
just got cold war the next game which is
not does not play like modern warfare so
it was
it's tough all these people are like i'm
looking for more modern warfare you know
the
war zone can only carry you so far but
it's gone back to classic arcade style
like in cold war
and that's just not pleasing everybody
honestly like we want the best for both
audiences
we feel like the modern warfare fans
deserve another season and we feel like
the cold war fans deserve
the best year that they can possibly
have and the problem is like convincing
activision to like
not just lump the two games together the
way that they've already done it
right it's it's also sticky for that too
like if activision knew what they had
they could have continued to support
modern warfare for another year
it's gonna be a tricky call to make
because activision you know
continue on with the yearly cycle or do
they finally try something different but
at the wrong time
so that brings us to the question that
we posed to
you guys last week which is there's some
chatter right now and and i want to be
clear that this is completely
speculation nobody knows for sure we're
going to get these announcements
sometime during spring the question we
posed you last week was if battlefield
or call of duty go into historical
settings
are you still happy with that this year
like is that enough for you
or does that kind of mess up your plans
so that brings us back to some of your
guys's comments
we have one from sean here who says if
the next call of duty is a retro game
i will be playing battlefield this year
i don't think cod can go back to world
war ii now
because of the war zone implementation
uh we're already sort of suspending
disbelief with
cod cold war and their integration with
war zone because it kind of conflicts
with timelines there's some fantasy
elements like
zombies but to go back that far
to world war ii i don't know how or if
they'll try to incorporate it into
something like warzone which is
their money maker they're gonna have to
figure out a way to do it and i don't
know if world war ii is the right move
we've got a comment here from rita who
says i don't know if activision realizes
that lots of
modern warfare 2019 players are
battlefield fans that shifted away from
battlefield
since the last entry was a disaster and
modern warfare was a great substitute
yet if activision keeps on trying hard
to push modern warfare down just for
cold war to have a better display
they must be aware that if the upcoming
battlefield is something like
battlefield 3 or battlefield 4
activision could kiss modern warfare
goodbye and it's true she goes on to say
that modern warfare has a lot of
potential
and the angle or release of cod games is
killing its predecessors
this is a summary of what we're talking
about here and that's the question we'll
raise to you guys in the comments down
below
can activision afford to break the
yearly cycle
as always thank you guys so much for
your comments we love to read them and
use them here on the show
it's a great way for us to reach back
out to you and talk more call of duty if
you want to see more call of duty check
out our gamespot
youtube page we've got a bunch of videos
and playlists of all things call of duty
including our brand new evolution of the
m16 it's been in just about
every call of duty game so i think you
should check it out and as always
thanks for watching leave a like
subscribe if you want more
and we'll see you next time
you